[Music]
ah
summer break i get that summer is fun
for kids and everything but does every
damn disney cartoon have to take place
in the summer so do you want cheese on
that hun
having to ask someone if they want
cheese on their burger dairy allergy is
the only excuse for not wanting cheese
on a burger
rest assured there's a perfectly logical
explanation show begins but then
immediately rewinds to catch you up to
the present cliche
rubbing your face on swine what is this
is that the konami code
i have zero understanding of how this
may play out in the show but so help me
if they're just inserting it here for
chuckles and fan
winks that is an abuse of the code which
by the way is for video games and not
videos
also this says stan is not what he seems
and honestly is anyone surprised by this
i mean if i'm going to spend time
deciphering a caesar cipher tell me
something i couldn't figure out on my
own damn it
it all began when our parents decided we
could use some fresh air
i believe you meant it all began when
your parents decided that they were
going to have sex that summer whenever
and wherever they wanted but semantics
this is a terrible way to distribute
sunscreen my sister tended to look on
the bright side of things
grass is 100 effective at helping you
look on the bright side of things
i mean so i've heard ladies and
gentlemen behold
the sas crotch you know this show can be
really funny which makes terrible jokes
like this stand out all the more
he's looking at it he's looking at it
here's a baffling decision to create a
12 year old character that is insanely
boy crazy
so crazy in fact that the rest of the
episode hinges on her prepubescent
horniness for boys kisses and god knows
what else
can we stop it with the horned up
children cartoon or not
dipper needs to get some newspaper on
that glass quick or that wipe job will
definitely leave streaks
oh my gosh you like turtles i like
turtles too
what is happening here so mabel's
supposed to be 12 but turtle guy looks
to be at least 28.
could they not find an actor that looked
younger to play the part grunkle stan
whenever i'm in those woods i feel like
i'm being watched
and you probably are by that 28 year old
who's obsessed with turtles
why does grunkle stan even put signs up
in the forest there's not a defined road
through here that anyone would be
driving on
so are they just making sure they don't
miss out on random hikers floating
eyeballs are they watching me
i mean i guess that's a valid question
when you see floating eyeballs but we
don't have to question and study
everything
some things we should just scream our
asses off and hightail it out of there
and get this after a certain point the
pages just
stop like the guy who was writing it
mysteriously disappeared
or he just decided to quit writing
because it wasn't paying the bills and
he needed to get a real job
see mom people really do want mulder and
scully fan fiction
sorry i might have had a flashback there
well time to spill the beans
but is it funny if there are no beans
actually spilling out of the can i mean
why go through all the trouble to set up
the can of beans if there are no beans
in the can
in the half hour i was gone you already
found a boyfriend
moving past the awkwardness of a 12 year
old going on a date let's clarify that
she said she had a date a date is very
different than having a boyfriend
are you bleeding norman
it's jam fine maybe norman could get
away with that but why is no one asking
about the branch and blade of grass
protruding from his head and considering
we find out that this is several gnomes
impersonating a human male
why did they choose to put a branch of
blade of grass there in the first place
based on what we've seen of the mystery
shack
grunkle stan is collecting whatever junk
he can find to display so there is zero
chance this attic wouldn't look like a
hoarder's wet dream this is a barren
addict of lies
but you gotta have evidence otherwise
people are gonna think you're a major
league cuckoo clock
i guess twitter hasn't made its way to
gravity falls yet my sister could be in
trouble it was time to get some evidence
using your sister a zombie bait for
someone whose lips were sucked 32 inches
into a leaf blower you're surprisingly
lack inflammation and irritation your
cheek however looks right
up you think he might be a vampire that
would be so
awesome would it though i always feel
like i'm missing something important
when it comes to understanding why a
vampire would be attractive to anyone
in the con column i have they kill you
they make you undead
they're bored with you because they've
lived too damn long and they probably
smell bad
and in the pro column i wrote pasta parm
basic force cereal
uh that's where my grocery list went
hold on i just need to add one last
thing here
perfect it all adds up the bleeding the
limp
actually it doesn't all add up because
once again norman is several gnomes so
why was he ever bleeding
when we see the gnomes later they're not
bleeding finally
we're alone yes
alone but this isn't the first time
they've been alone right
so why hasn't norman revealed his true
purpose before now long story short us
gnomes have been
looking for a new queen so we're just
skipping over how the gnomes managed to
bend the solid arm sticks at their
non-existent elbow joints this whole
time we're just skipping right over that
because we're gonna kidnap you huh mabel
might be a kid but she's big enough to
be able to handle five
gnomes well really it's four gnomes and
schmeberlock
so this kidnapping seems not only
arbitrary but also impossible
don't worry mabel i'll save you from
that zombie good thing you know exactly
where she is in these massive woods
tasting the rainbow gnomes little men of
the gravity falls forest
but the picture shows four fingers and a
thumb while none of the gnomes have more
than three fingers
so is this a mistake or a clue and sure
you might say watch the show and find
out for yourself to which i say
paul has four fingers this picture has
four fingers this book shows five
fingers
four fingers three fingers here here
here and here
but then purple lady has four here
grandma has four
sues has four stan has four but the kids
have
three yeah i'm gonna go with continuity
error and try my best to never care this
much about phalanges again
geez how low on the totem pole do you
have to be to get tongue duty
why would this thing even need a tongue
how is that helpful in any way
i'll get you back for this
and what's stopping jeff and the gnomes
from getting them back they know where
mabel is and they can just mighty
morphin up later and attack again right
how are they going to sleep soundly
tonight and i will have a
grappling hook i can't go this entire
video without giving some love to mabel
be it in the writing or the awesome
kristen shawlness of the character
she makes me laugh a lot and man do we
need laughter these days
but who knows what other secrets are
waiting to be unlocked whatever those
secrets are they shouldn't be too hard
to unlock
considering that long after you punch
them in this super secret door leaves
the keypad lights on for you who
designed this thing motel 6.
it's a trap if you've ever wanted to
know what it's like to probe into the
back end of cinema sins and learn our
deepest darkest secrets behind the sins
podcast is just what you need each week
writers aaron that's me today that's me
and jonathan yep discuss what it takes
to create the content that you enjoy
on youtube hopefully enjoy they probably
do i mean even if they don't we talk
about it that's true i guess i'll just
wrap this up real quick
and let you know that you can listen to
behind the scenes here on youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep christine charles
horse
kristen charles oh my gosh you like
turtles
i like turtles hey this is dean trumbull
for the mattress man
what is that that's what we're gonna
find out
look lenny i gotta know what do the
numbers mean
in gravity falls there is no one you can
trust
[Music]
[Applause]
norman are you bleeding blood
blood
and this is in case you see a pinata
gnomes of the forest assemble
your powers combined i am captain planet
one thing about living in santa carla i
never could stomach
all the damn vampires